on december 2nd
1823 u.s president james monroe was
giving his annual state of the union
address to congress when he threw in a
couple of remarks about the united
states relationship with the powers of
europe he said the american continents
by the free and independent condition
which they have assumed and maintained
are henceforth not to be considered as
subjects for future colonization by any
european powers
in the wars of the european powers and
matters relating to themselves we have
never taken any part nor does it comport
with our policy to do so we owe it
therefore to candor and to the amicable
relations existing between the united
states and those powers to declare that
we should consider any attempt on their
part to extend their system to any
portion of this hemisphere as dangerous
to our peace and safety so basically in
one fell swoop james monroe
told the crowned heads of europe to stay
out
of the americas
he said
as far as i'm concerned the era of
colonization is over
so stop giving us the side eye
stop looking at your maps and trying to
decide where you might place a little
colony next no more european
colonization in the americas what's more
don't interfere
the americas are the united states is
concerned so we don't want the powers of
europe to meddle in any of the affairs
of latin america or south america you
can keep your system
and by system monroe meant monarchy
out of the americas this is the
hemisphere of democracy
so this is an incredibly bold statement
let's not forget here that the united
states is not exactly a world power in
1823 they could at best be said to be a
minor power even in the americas the
united states is not a major world
military power it's not a major world
navy power and let's remember that in
this era having a strong navy was
tantamount to being able to take over
the world they're kind of a second-rate
nation in a second-rate part of the
world so what was the response when the
united states made this incredibly bold
assertion that they would not permit any
more colonization or interference in the
americas from europe
crickets
nobody really cared
to the established powers of europe the
united states was no more than a little
mosquito buzzing around maybe making a
lot of noise a bit annoying but pretty
easy to swat no matter how much noise
the united states made the only thing
that mattered to the great powers of the
world was whether or not the united
states could enforce
the monroe doctrine which with such a
weak military presence they certainly
could not nevertheless the monroe
doctrine
became
a key facet of american
foreign policy throughout the 19th
century and into the 20th century it
became a justification for manifest
destiny
and would play a major role in the
foreign policies of teddy roosevelt and
franklin delano roosevelt
so where did the monroe doctrine come
from well let's take a minute to look at
some of the major world events at the
time period and the major players who
brought the monroe doctrine about
all right dateline 1820
it has been a bad couple of years for
monarchy in europe for one thing the
napoleonic wars and the french
revolution have been convulsing the
powers of europe
for several years
by 1815 the revolution has more or less
finished and the
monarchies of europe
have been reinstated
but
this revolutionary fervor coming from
the french revolution coming also from
the american revolution has started to
spread and so movements for independence
are now taking hold in south america
there's a chilean movement for
independence
argentinian movement for independence
venezuelan movement for independence so
they've kind of caught the democracy bug
the people in the united states are
cheering for their southern brethren
saying
excellent work picking up democracy
breaking away from old-fashioned
monarchical tyrannical europe we're
totally on your side but it's easier to
make an independence movement happen
when the home country is distracted with
another war aka the napoleonic wars and
once the napoleonic wars are over the
monarchies of europe start saying hmm
you know what since spain is in control
of these nations now spain has the time
and energy to consider maybe putting
down
these revolutions
so they're no longer distracted by war
and they have the manpower and the
bandwidth to think about maybe trying to
reinstate or secure spanish rule in
south america where nations have been in
the process of revolution now we don't
know the extent to which spain was
actually planning on putting these
revolutions down but we do know that the
united states and england were very
concerned that the monarchies of the
continents france and spain
might
join together and try to put down all of
these revolutions now why wouldn't they
want that well for the most part it kind
of came down to markets now if you think
back to early american colonial society
the economic system was known as
mercantilism
and mercantilism is the practice of
colonies kind of existing to enrich the
mother country so
all trade
goes through the home country and that
means that the home country is going to
be making sure that the colonies are not
trading with any other international
partners because they want to be the
ones who are enriched by the natural
resources of the colonies so when chile
and argentina and venezuela revolt from
spain it means that their markets are
now
opened up
to the united states
and to england
and so england and the united states are
not eager to see
these new nations
be returned to their colonial status
because thanks to mercantilism they're
not going to be able to trade with them
anymore so with this idea in mind
the british foreign secretary a man
named george
canning
approached
the american secretary of state john
quincy adams
and he said
why don't we make a joint proclamation
between the united states and great
britain saying that the powers of europe
should not interfere in the new world
and john quincy adams thought hmm
i'm not sure if i like you british folks
remember that the war of 1812
had not taken place too
long beforehand the united states was
not quite ready to be friends with the
united kingdom yet and they were a
little bit afraid that if the united
states made a joint declaration with
england that it would seem a little bit
like a flea on the back of a rottweiler
saying don't mess with us or we'll bite
you right the united states didn't have
nearly the strength to actually make an
equal partnership so it might have
looked a little bit like they were
hiding behind the british in a joint
declaration but jqa thought this
actually still sounded like a pretty
good plan so he floated the idea to
president james monroe
now there's kind of a
movement of nationalism going on at this
time in the united states so even though
the united states didn't technically win
the war of 1812 they kind of felt like
they had and so they're
busy kind of creating a new
nationalist
rhetoric in the united states they're
feeling pretty good about themselves you
know they stood up to their old foe of
great britain and won or at the very
least didn't lose but to them it was
kind of the same thing so john quincy
adams crafts for james monroe what will
become known as the monroe doctrine now
monroe is not only concerned about the
possibility of european powers coming
down here and trying to start fights
with each other over the fate of south
america monroe was also worried about
russia
who had recently made some territorial
claims
in canada saying that their territory
should come all the way down there and
the russians have started putting some
forts
on the coast of california um close to
modern-day san francisco so monroe sees
the old monarchical powers of europe
sort of encroaching both from the north
and the south here and so in 1823 he
makes the announcement of the monroe
doctrine he says no more colonization
russia get out of there
and no more interference in general
so don't try to turn these new republics
back into colonies under the rule of
monarchies in fact just keep your
monarchy out of our hemisphere
altogether
so monroe makes this statement
completely outside of the relationship
with the united kingdom so it doesn't
have this kind of riding on the
coattails feeling of being allied with
britain but nevertheless the only way
that the united states can actually
count on the monroe doctrine being
enforced is because the british navy is
so incredibly powerful i'm gonna draw a
very bad boat here
but
nobody who heard about the monroe
doctrine thought oh man we better not
make the united states angry what they
thought was oh man we better not make
the british empire angry because they
knew that the british navy which wanted
neutrality of the seas which wanted to
be able to continue to have these trade
relationships with new nations in south
america would defend the neutrality and
the independence of south america by
proxy and by doing so kind of enforce
the monroe doctrine so this is
interesting you could think of this as
being a little bit weasely on the part
of monroe declaring that the americas
should remain free of the influence of
europe but counting on the united
kingdom to enforce it or you could think
of it as perhaps a brilliant policy
maneuver i don't know certainly the
nations of south america and latin
america appreciated this declaration of
independence for the americas coming
from the united states but they
certainly knew that it was more about
the united states making sure that they
themselves were protected than wanting
to have a real equal partnership with
south america so the monroe doctrine
really didn't amount to much for most of
the 19th century it was certainly a
justification as the united states
continued to push west in their quest of
manifest destiny but it will become
increasingly important in the 20th
century as the united states steps onto
the world stage with things like the
spanish-american war
under
the
auspices of william mckinley and making
famous theodore roosevelt
saying that the caribbean is the
province of the united states and the
nations of latin america and south
america they're only to be dealt with
through the united states so you can see
the monroe doctrine as a very early
expression of the united states's
intention to become a world power and to
be the leading and most powerful nation
in the americas and you can also see it
as an expression of american
isolationism
which will really be
the
leading aspect
of american foreign policy up until the
spanish-american war as early as george
washington's farewell address washington
expressed the view that the united
states should just not get involved in
the business of europe that that would
only lead to heartbreak while the monroe
doctrine is now kind of taking not only
that idea that the united states should
not become involved in the affairs of
europe but also turning it around and
saying that europe should not become
involved in the affairs of the americas
drawing an even stronger barrier between
the old world and the new